riesige anomalie unter den usa 3000 mal
würfel glühender kohlenstoff unter den
vereinigten staaten als die menschheit
im jahr an co2 ausstößt was das für die
vereinigten staaten und das klima
bedeutet jetzt praktisch fix herzlich
gekommen metro 583 zwischen sensoren
gelang es wissenschaftlern aus
frankreich und großbritannien die
gigantische massen an kohlenstoff unter
dem westen der usa ausfindig zu machen
insgesamt schlummern in einer tiefe von
350 kilometern und verteilt auf mehr als
18 millionen quadratkilometer und 100
millionen tonnen geschmolzenem
kunststoff machen wir hier sieht
erschrecken sich die betroffenen region
wirklich fast über die halbe landmasse
der usa insgesamt haben sie eine größe
von mexiko ungefähr und treten diese
flüssigen blut gesteine auch nur
vereinzelt an die erdoberfläche könne
dies wirklich verheerende folgen haben
satz vater ihrem album der vom kollektor
fairway an der university of london ist
der meinung dass man ein prozent der
ausfindig gemachten elemente in sofern
sie an die erdoberfläche gelangen mit
dem co2 ausstoß von 23 millionen tonnen
verbranntem öl vergleichen kann den
klimawandel würde so ein ereignis also
rasant beschleunigt wenn sonst die rede
vom klimawandel ist sprechen die
experten fast ausschließlich von dem vom
menschen erzeugten co2 ausstoß dass die
erde selbst ganz ohne das zutun des
menschen den klimawandel beeinflusst
wird dagegen eher selten thematisiert bz
zitat wir denken vielleicht nicht
darüber nach dass die struktur im
erdinneren eine auswirkung auf den
klimawandel haben kann
die entdeckung zeigt aber nicht nur eine
unterirdische landkarte sondern gibt
auch hinweise auf die erdatmosphäre wie
sie in zukunft aussehen kann so dass
vater hier maxime der da es wie hier
majumdar weiter erklärt forschern
unmöglich ist sich dem hohen stoffmantel
zu nähern
liebe der wissenschaft aktuell nichts
anderes übrig als weiter mitmischen
sensoren zu arbeiten und deren daten zu
interpretieren detaillierte zahlen
werden wir in naher zukunft also nicht
erwarten können ersten vermutungen
zufolge hätte sich vor 80 millionen
jahren die fahrbahnplatte unter das kvk
vierte gebiet geschoben
diese ist mit co2 und wasser
angereichert wahnsinn 100 millionen
tonnen flüssiger kunststoff unter den
usa all diese lagerstätten sowie auf
kohle und öl im erdmantel speichern
kohlenstoff und haben dafür gesorgt dass
wir genügend sauerstoff in der
erdatmosphäre haben wenn wir diese
lagerstätten aufbrauchen bzw
zb durch vulkanausbrüche zu viel
kohlenstoff oxidiert und als co2 in die
erdatmosphäre gelang dann droht die erde
durch den folgenden klimawandel nicht
nur zu heiß zu werden sondern gänzlich
ungewohnt zu werden hier könnt ihr wie
ein abo aufs auge drücken vergessen ich
die glocke zu läuten und ansonsten
bestand bleibt dran